non-minimalists
ryan we got a question from simba simba
is rob bell still a christian
[Laughter]
rob thought 140 characters i think he
would say i wrote a 300 page book about
that to answer your question
and this literal question answers in the
book which is great yeah
um well i mean i'll give you a pithy
answer and then maybe we can expand on
it labels are useful but not as powerful
as everyday actions
um yeah doesn't it mean
would you maybe answer that question
with a question like what do you mean by
christian two characters
of course
that's the pithiest answer ever
that is all i did you could tweet of
course too and like it would just like
people would just like i needed that
today especially like when
that's all the entire west coast is on
fire and rob just tweets
of course of course
often what presents itself as religion
is actually a fairly sophisticated egoic
structure
in which the ego grasps and clings to
labels
for a sense of safety a sense of
identity a sense of division
us against them yeah uh a false sense of
security about some coming doom
or judgment so what's really interesting
in the teachings of jesus
he's constantly inviting you
to the love that doesn't need to cling
or grasp
because it's been belonged the entire
time
yeah so litmus test questions um
questions that have a hermeneutic of
suspicion in them
which is um
the the world is sliding off a cliff and
are you
i think you're part of it or are you
it's all built
it's not built around trust it's not
built around a big
buoyant sense that the whole thing is
headed in some
fascinating new direction oh wow it's
birthed out of
mistrust or distrust in a way yeah so
like uh hermeneutic is how you read
something
right so a hermeneutic of suspicion is
uh and then you think about for many
people for roughly 1400 years in western
culture you've had this idea of original
sin
which is that which is deepest within a
human is wrong
off broken sinful so
no wonder people end up not able to
trust their own
inner knowing they've been taught that
if you look far enough inside of
yourself
all you'll see is evil and darkness but
what's fascinating is the actual
tradition begins genesis 1
all human beings bear the divine image
that which is deepest within you
is good yeah of course you we have
tremendous capacities to make a mess of
things
nobody's fuzzy on this but you can see
often this hermeneutic of suspicion that
reads
are you still what are you what are you
i i need
you to give me certain words so that i
can feel
is um rooted in a way of viewing what it
means to be human
that you need labels and things to
redeem you
as opposed to you've belonged
the whole time yeah are you on my team
or are you the enemy
yeah the underlying question quite often
it's always funny when religious people
especially people on the jesus tradition
their dominant energies are
moving away from the very things jesus
invites us to be liberated from
he comes to liberate us from questions
that take us in the direction we don't
actually want to be going that aren't
freedom
joy peace non-violence
[Laughter]
i love the uh you talked about the story
in your book of the
farmer who like hired the workers and
they showed up at different times during
the day
but they all get paid the same the same
and
uh that doesn't make any sense you
cannot divide the infinite and there's
no pun he doesn't
and jesus doesn't say and here's the
punch line right he just goes on
right and uh there's also a story that
you don't talk about in your book it
reminded me of the guy who like dropped
everything when he found the pearl
yeah and i'm like and every time i read
the story i'm like this makes no sense
to me
like it has many different meanings i
guess i've heard it explained different
ways
but ultimately um what that
helped me do that part in your book is
start to be comfortable with
not understanding things and you start
off with the quantum physics how you
know there's basically chaos going on
like unexplained chaos and then you
you know there's a macro view of it of
like well we have unexplained chaos that
goes on in the world
and uh and i think religion helps people
find
an answer to all that chaos sure it
helps them organize it yeah yeah holds
it together but the secret is and you
you talk about this
with you know the buddha and jesus and
all the priests and the monks
they got this smile on their face
because they get it
they're like yeah there's a lot of stuff
going on yeah blessed is the one who's
in on the joke
yeah everybody shows up at different
times and gets paid the same amount